In many ways Rochester was forced to rediscover who it was without its corporate titans.
The process was difficult marked by uncertainty and big losses, but over the next two decades
Rochester would undergo a remarkable transformation rooted in innovation, education, and community
resilience.
One of the first pillars of Rochester's comeback was its institutions.
U of R and RIT stepped into leadership roles, not just as educators, but as engines of
research, innovation, and job creation.
The U of R Medical Center grew into one of the largest employers in the region, driving
advancements in healthcare and biomedical research.
Meanwhile, RIT's strong programs in engineering, computer science, and the arts attracted talent
from across the country and played a crucial role in developing Rochester's new future.
Rather than linger on its past, the city began to leverage its innovative roots.
Rochester's legacy in optics, imaging, and manufacturing became the foundation for a growing
tech movement and a vibrant startup culture began to take form.
Former engineers from Kodak and Xerox, as well as new graduates, began launching companies
of their own.
With help from local incubators and entrepreneurship programs, Rochester started to see the rise
of small businesses such as the two on this tour, ITX and Envative.
This new generation helped shift the city's economy from being reliant on a few large employers
to one driven by innovation and diversity.